ahora hablemos de venezuela porque desde
hace tiempo hay unas deudas con
entrenadores de atletas de selecciones
nacionales y este martes nuestro
compañero juan pupiales conversó con el
técnico de la medallista mundial del
salto con garrocha rovelli peinado el
ucraniano vyacheslav kalinichenko él
denunció que el ministerio del deporte
le debe 20 mil 300 dólares kalinichenko
también mencionó a otros entrenadores
que están en la misma situación entre
ellos el preparador del campeón olímpico
de espada en londres-2012 rubén limardo
se trata de ruperto gascón con el
conversamos y nos comentó que su equipo
tiene a 20 atletas entrenando en polonia
pero solo recibe recursos para uno
bueno pero yo le dan algo nuevo por
decir algo para la preparación de rubén
mi mano pero esto es para la preparación
de
normalmente saber cómo
nada me dio por gastos el dinero queda
bien es muy poco y es a veces se dan
cuenta gotas
éste
no nos va a llegar a la completa inicia
gustaría lona y ya pero para los demás
muchachos como hay absolutamente nada
esta situación también está golpeando el
fútbol porque el exdirector técnico jose
peseiro lo recibe su sueldo hace 14
meses si él ya confirmó que que le fue
pagada la deuda por eso fue que se logró
contratar también a josé pekerman como
nuevo seleccionador venezolano pero en
el caso de ruperto gas con él nos relata
que en su caso ni siquiera existe un
contrato que lo reconozca como director
técnico de la espada
fechas que el pasado año
[Música]
el mundo
entonces como se están sosteniendo 20
atletas en el extranjero todos estos
atletas incluyendo el propio rubén
limardo tienen empleos regulares y ese
es otro de los problemas que atraviesa
el equipo de spas
ahora no trabajen ve a entrenar
como te digo y parte de todo
[Música]
el equipo
pérez
son cosas que los atletas deberían tener
por lo menos una vez